yo here we go
500 national guard troops will be on
standby in wisconsin for rittenhouse
verdict as police forces across america
brace for acquittal
yeah it does seem extremely likely there
will be an acquittal but my friends we
have an update on on today's news it
definitely seems like the prosecution
has
thrown a hail mary pass
might actually get
they could potentially get all counts
you see the prosecutors were able to
introduce fake evidence because the
judge didn't get it because the defense
didn't get it and now the jury will be
told that that computer generated images
is actually video from the night in
question and i'm just sitting here like
how how did this happen how did the
defense screw this one up we got andrew
bronk over at legal insurrection says
written written house trial day nine
prosecution big win on provocation
lacking any factual rebuttal to
self-defense the state will argue that
kyle rittenhouse was a provoker with
intent eliminating self-defense
privilege under wisconsin law that
cannot be regained by withdrawal from
the fight now here's where here's what's
important
what you see on the screen for those
that are watching
yeah tell me what that is no no for real
if you're if you're watching right now
if you're watching live if you're if
you're watching on a youtube clip that
image on the screen i'd like you to
comment and say what it is
because
it's a hunter bite
yes what what is it what do you guys
think it is this guy's holding a sign i
think my favorite comment was it was a
sign going through a state of being
raptured
oh because it's expanding yeah yeah all
right let me explain
on the right side is a small image and
you can see a sign and you can see some
blurry looking
people
on the left is the ai enhanced image
that you can clearly see is not enhanced
at all take a look at the sign it's got
a ghost sign behind it or emerging from
it i don't know that is why because a
computer attempted to decipher what a
larger version or a clearer version
would be and this image is actually
nonsense
they introduced this image on the left
which by their own admission was
enhanced by an artif by an algorithm
which means a computer generated the
image
not a sensor capturing light from the
day in question that is to say the
prosecution was able to admit evidence
that they say shows cal right now is
pointing a weapon at someone but it's
not real it is not actually a photo from
the night in question and the judge said
oh i guess we'll just let the jury
decide now it's going to happen in
closing arguments the prosecutors will
say definitively as a statement of fact
we showed you a video clip
and image of kyle rittenhouse pointing
his gun at these people so it's no
wonder why rosenbaum attacked him in
fact rosenbaum was acting in
self-defense not kyle rittenhouse as a
statement of effect they can now make
that claim and the jury might be like oh
well if that's true
the only thing the defense can say is
come on you couldn't actually see what
was in that video and they'll be like
well but the prosecutor didn't is not
lying is he
he's not lying he's not so i would like
to present to all of you my um
algorithmically enhanced image from that
night yes this is uh as you can see uh
right here
that is kyle rittenhouse you can tell
because he's got an angry face and his
mouth is a squiggly line and this thing
in his hand it's not a boomerang in fact
it's a handgun because he had a handgun
and then these these these two are the
people and you can clearly see he's
pointing his weapon they're very now i
would like to state definitively i
showed you a picture of kyle rittenhouse
pointing a gun at people technically
correct well it was a drawing no no no
it's a picture is a drum that's as real
as the drawing of a picture a drawing is
a picture i can say as a statement of
fact i have a photo i have i have a
picture of kyle right now pointing a gun
at people i mean stick figures i drew it
just now in 10 seconds that's what the
prosecution's doing and they're getting
away with it yeah they showed a drawing
of a picture that's what that is that's
what it is a computer drawing of uh i
got to tell you what's really amazing is
they they they kept doing this when the
judge was like okay i got to decide on
instructions play the video for me the
prosecutor goes put it on the 4k screen
and the defense goes
you can't because that will add pixels
and the prosecutor goes you don't know
that and he goes it's common sense and
the judge said nothing and sits down and
watches okay
it's simple
a 4k screen which i'm pretty sure the
screen we have here is 4k has you know
what is it it's it's 4k because it's
effectively 4000 pixels it's a little
bit more than that uh that means when i
zoom in
pixels on the screen in front of us
have to be filled in with pixels that
don't exist so this is what they this is
what computer programs do for digital
zoom it guesses what they might be which
is why when you look at the image on the
left the sign has a ghost look look no
frill like you can see there's a sign
and there's a ghost sign behind it like
you said being raptured
because the computer has no idea it's
guessing and the judge felt falls right
for it he just walks right into it and
the defense did nothing and
now the jury might just be like all
right fine whatever if he pointed it
then the case is it's case closed isn't
it fortunately you don't base a core
proceeding off of a blurry picture if
there was more evidence of him pointing
guns video and pictures then i think
this would be this might have some
substance and what the defense has
argued
and might work is they they wouldn't
just say it's a blurry image what
they've said is if that image
does show kyle rittenhouse pointing a
weapon it's with his left hand which
means he has to take the weapon off
flip the strap to his other shoulder and
then change his hands and then point it
which
would not have yeah it would never
happen i mean i i would look at that
picture and i would have said as the
defense how can you tell me uh
definitively where his face is in that
photo how do you know what direction
he's even pointing and then i would have
the the guy circle what he tells me is
the weapon and i would have said okay
what you're claiming is the rifle in
this photo accounts for maybe six or
eight pixels of the entire thing there's
no possible way that you can discern
what is a rifle and what is the sling
and you can't even tell me whether he's
facing uh toward the camera or away from
the camera in this photo so how i just
it it blows my mind that
i mean not only that but that line of
questioning is for the original right
not the enhanced for the enhanced i
would just say
is the enhanced image a photograph from
the night in question
right and the answer is no no and then
you say okay that's why are we taking it
it's a computer i would actually say the
photo on the left when was that file
created and he'd say last week and i'd
say where in my crime lab and i'd say so
it's not it's not an image created on
the night in question no your honor i
move to have this evidence removed from
the court as it's not an image from the
night in question
yeah not to mention weren't they saying
that he was pointing the rifle at
zaminsky in that photo yeah but but uh
that still is provocation um well that's
fine but then i would say uh why don't
we have zaminski here as a complaining
witness because he endangered him just
in the same way he's being criminally
charged exactly so
if you if if you're claiming that he
pointed a rifle at this person and
that's what provoked the entire attack
and this person is not there and is not
being charged uh how can we how can we
move forward i'm going to do this i'm
going to do this ladies and gentlemen um
what i have before you right here you
can see in this picture this is ada
binger
this is um the prosecutor banger
pointing a gun at that's kyle
rittenhouse
i have a picture
of the prosecutor in the case pointing a
gun at kyle rittenhouse oh my goodness
that's right
i moved to dismiss as it is
a drawing of a picture
it is it's it is a drawing but drawings
are pictures and and and and i'm holding
it
uh for the funny thing is people who
listen to this can't see this so that's
kind of the point when i say i have a
picture of the prosecutor pointing a gun
at kyle rittenhouse it's literally a
stick figure and there's a squiggly line
in a circle like crude on purpose to
make my point so there you go it is now
a statement of fact that tim paul has a
picture of ada binger pointing a gun
recklessly i might add yeah at the
defendant check out right now with
malice with malista yeah yeah i'll say
this the picture shows murderous intent
indeed yeah because you do have squiggly
oh you do not have squiggly eyebrows but
you definitely have a yelling face yes
yeah that's why it's a circle let me let
me let me modify it and i'll put angry
eyes angry eyebrows angry eyebrows but a
big angry mouth there look nice got
angry eyebrows i don't know if you can
actually see it that's malice school
children
school children around this country had
cops called for them for similar uh
egregious actions like you just
committed to him just a heads up yeah
remember the kid who chewed his pop tart
into the shape of a gun
and the cops came like are you freaking
kidding me but so like here's a really
good example of what you're dealing with
though right so we have
false evidence that has been admitted
because you have a judge who is trying
to retain the regalia of the court he
wants he i think he's coming in good
faith
and i think one one of the things that
we saw this last week was that the
constant interaction between the judge
and binger was that the judge was
consistently disappointed with his
actions like
he was hoping that binger was going to
come and act as a prosecuting attorney
should within the decorum of the court
and so as you saw
bingor continuously bring things forward
that were either a overtly malicious in
the way that he was very manipulative in
his conversation i get it
when you're in a court of law and you're
arguing your case you have to become
very articulate with what you're saying
but there's a difference between trying
to make sure that the witness defines
something and trying to change what the
witness said
to say a certain thing and so now
our judge our judge schroeder is in a
situation where he is mitigating between
two people two groups parties whatever
two parties and one of them is at least
acting within the court the rules of the
court and one of them is deliberately
not
and he i think he's in a situation
combined with this is probably the the
most important case that judge has ever
ruled over in his entire life he already
wants to end it undoubtedly he's saying
like i want to start a new trial on
monday let's get it over with yeah this
will be the most historical event of his
life whether he knows it or not
basically the reason i'm sorry i got i
got to bronco's uh analysis is brilliant
brilliant guy um because i'm reading
this and i can see the strategy now of
the state we've been sitting here
laughing at the state about how stupid
they are but they've been waiting to the
very last moment and check this out
branca says the state will argue this
pointing of the rifle did trigger a
violent response from rosenbaum
rittenhouse then led the provoked
rosenbomb across the parking lot where
kyle ultimately acted on his intent to
use rosenbaum's provoked attack as an
excuse to use deadly force basically
they're going to argue
in that video we showed you he pointed
his gun at him and then acting in
self-defense in defense of others
rosenbaum chased after him it was kyle's
intent to lead him to an open space to
get him away from a crowd where he could
kill him
that's intentional homicide
it's unbelievable and there was no
mention of that for the first uh week
and a half of the trial
so the defense is going to have to rely
on you saw him render aid you heard from
one witness a journalist on the scene
who said he was de-escalating violence
does that narrative really fit no i'm
pretty sure the prosecution gives their
closing argument last though don't they
i'm not the one to know they get the
final word
i could be wrong thank you i'm pretty
sure they get the final word in which
case they're going to be able to
craft their narrative around what uh i
think there's a rebuttal a half an hour
rebuttal yeah so they'll give their
argument the defense will then come up
and give it and get a half an hour i
think that's what the judge actually
ruled but the i i i ultimately i still
think most people who have seen this
aren't buying into that and i've seen a
bunch of progressives now tweeting out
like he's going to be acquitted chris
hayes is is i think a big one he said
really yeah chris hayes at a monologue
and he was like he just paused and goes
based on what i've seen
i think an acquit acquittal is is going
to happen in all honesty and i was like
here come on you know if you've got
msnbc saying he's going to be acquitted
i think he's going to be acquitted i
mean i'll be honest with you i've been
pretty disappointed with the trial in
its entirety just because
seeing as how important this case is
going to be as a landmark for
future
use of force self-defense
you know people who conceal carry in
general
i'm very surprised at how
ill-prepared i think the defense was to
answer a lot of the questions that they
brought up especially as it pertained to
like the ammunition choice
the particulars of the weapons you know
they were talking using terms like
re-rack the slide on an ar-15 they got
this female cop up there who's um you
know just not even using the right
terminology they first they said uh he
should have had hollow points and then
at some point they were trying to
insinuate that his fmj ammo was designed
to go through police armor vests right
right right you have all these cops up
there and look you know
i can i can talk about my well let's
all day long but like these guys are not
firearms experts okay cops are not
firearms experts by alec baldwin was
talking about how the solution for
hollywood is to have a police officer on
set to clear firearms i'll tell you this
in all the professional i've done
almost 400 hours of professional
firearms training the only two times
i've had a loaded gun pointed at my head
were by police officers
and and that's not to you know
insinuate they're all bad but thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you